All the talk today is about are
we going to see inflation
or deflation.
And before we do that, I think
it's really important to get a
microeconomic level
understanding of why do prices
increase or decrease.
We'll do a little example of
me starting a business and
when do the prices increase or
decrease in that market?
So let's say I wanted to start
a cupcake factory.
And then actually in the process
of this video, even
though this isn't the intent of
this playlist The intent of
this playlist is eventually for
you to be able to go to
your econ professor and say, no,
we won't or we will have
inflation or deflation for
reasons x, y, and z.
But in the process you might
learn a little bit about
accounting and starting
a cupcake factory.
So let's say I want to start
It costs a million
dollars to build.
And just the economics of the
factory is it costs $500,000 a
year to operate.
So that's literally to pay the
electric bills, to have people
sitting there ready to make
cupcakes, and I have
accountants and all the rest.
I have to pay people
to clean the place.
Let's say the economics of the
cupcakes themselves-- The cost
per cupcake is $1.
Let me do that in red.
I'll do all of these in red
because these are-- I'll do
that later.
So the cost per cupcake
is a dollar.
And where does that cost?
Some of it is the incremental--
Let's assume
that I had a completely
automated, robotic factory.
Let's say there's very little
labor at my factory.
And this is just the cost of
ingredients: cream, and sugar,
and butter, and those little
wax paper things that the
cupcake is held in, and the
electricity to run my robots,
and then overtime to kind of
maintain the robots that make
my factory.
Let's say I think that I can
charge $2 per cupcake.
Oh and one other thing, my $1
million factory can produce
one million cupcakes per year.
So this is a couple
of exercises.
Because I'm a businessman, I'm
not just going to plunk down a
million dollars before
I figure out how
much money I can make.
Let's think about how much
money we can make
in different scenarios.
Let's call this scenario
one, which is
kind of the best scenario.
So call this the optimistic
optimist-- is that I sell a
million cupcakes.
So my factory can produce a
million cupcakes and I sell a
million cupcakes.
If I sell one million cupcakes--
And I'll take a
side here because this is
an issue that I want
to bring up a lot.
I am fully utilized.
My factory can produce one
million cupcakes and, in this
scenario, I'm producing
a million cupcakes.
So we would say we're
100% utilized.
How much are you producing
relative to
what you can produce?
100%
So, if I sell a million
cupcakes,
what would be my revenue?
And I won't go into the
details of accounting.
Let me make revenue in green
because that's a good thing.
So what is my revenue?
If my background weren't already
black, I would make
that in black.
That's why people say being in
the black or being in the red.
Because being in the black
means you're positive and
being in the red means
you're negative.
But my background is black
so I'll use green.
So we'll say being
in the green.
So what would be my revenue?
Well, I'm selling one million
cupcakes and this is my
optimistic scenario.
Let's say I actually am able
to charge $2 per cupcake.
Obviously the whole discussion
is: what happens to this price
over a bunch of different
scenarios?
So I am able to charge $2 per
cupcake, so my revenue is
equal to $2 million per year.
Right?
This is a million cupcakes
per year.
What are my cost of goods?
And I'll write the common
acronym in there, COGS.
And this is what you'll see if
you actually look at income
statements for public
companies.
You'll see something like cost
of goods or variable costs.
Usually, actually, cost of goods
or cost of services is
what you'll see most often.
So if I have a million
cupcakes-- let me do this in
red, I said I would
do this in red.
So I have a million cupcakes
times-- what's my cost per
cupcake?-- times $1
cost per cupcake.
So it's $1 million per year.
And so what is my profit just
from selling the cupcakes?
Before I think about how much
does it cost for me, all of
the overhead expenses.
Just the money I'm getting from
selling the cupcakes, and
that term is called
gross profit.
And that's essentially
how much am I
bringing in from the cupcakes?
And then how much are just those
cupcakes costing me?
So I'll do a line here.
I'll subtract that from that.
So gross profit, I'm
making $1 million.
Two minus one.
You might say, oh
that's great!
You're making a million dollars
on your cupcake
factory in this scenario and
oh no, we're not done yet.
This is just the gross profit.
This is just the money directly
from the cupcakes.
I have all of this overhead
expense and often times, on a
regular income statement, it
will be called selling,
general and administrative, or
overhead costs, or operating
costs or something like that.
I'll just call it overhead.
I'll make it red because
it's an expense.
So this should be
red too: COGS.
So I'll call it overhead.
So once again, this is kind of
the offices, the accountants,
the bookkeepers.
So that's going to be
$500,000 a year.
And then, how much am I making
from the business now?
And this is called
operating profit.
How much am I making from
operating the business?
And I won't go into all of
the details of an income
statement, but any income
statement you look at will
have this operating
profit line.
And everything below the
operating profit line, just as
an aside, will kind of cover
things not related to the
actual operations
of the business.
It'll be expenses related to
financing the business if I
took a loan for that million
dollars, or it will be
expenses related to taxes
and all that.
But we're just assuming
an ideal world that
doesn't have taxes.
And let's say, assume if I
inherited this million
dollars, I didn't finance it.
So my operating profit is really
my profit because I
don't have to pay taxes on it.
So let's see, I got gross profit
just from selling the
cupcakes: a million.
Overhead: the accountants and
the people cleaning the
factory and et cetera,
et cetera.
That's $500,000 a year.
So my operating profit
is $500,000 and
that's pretty good.
I had a $1 million investment,
one time investment.
And I'm assuming that this
$500,000 a year to operate
also maintains my building.
So this kind of $1 million
investment will
exist forever, right?
And I'm making $500,000 a
year in this scenario.
So that's a 50% return,
right, which is great.
If I told you I had an
investment where I could make
50% a year on your money
you'd say here's my
money, here's a check.
But this is, of course, an
optimistic scenario.
Let's think of other
scenarios.
There's actually a ton of
scenarios because you can keep
adjusting how much you sell and
the price you sell it for
and come up with different
numbers here.
It's actually a fun exercise to
do in Excel and you could
do probability distributions
and all that, but I won't
worry about that right now.
Let's do a pessemistic--
actually
let's do this scenario.
What do I have to do just to
make sure that I don't lose
money, right?
So to make sure I don't
lose money, let's
kind of do it backwards.
So we're going to do a
break-even analysis.
And trust me, this will
eventually lead to whether
we're going to see inflation or
deflation in this economy.
And I think in the meantime
you might learn a little
interesting things about
starting a business.
So let's say I just want to know
what has to happen for my
operating profit to be zero.
Right?
To not be negative, what's the
minimum number of cupcakes I
need to make or what price
I have to charge.
So if my operating profit is
zero, we know my overhead.
This is fixed.
This is a fixed expense.
There's nothing I
can do about it.
If you want to have a
cupcake factory, it
will cost you $500,000.
And I'll write it as a negative
number because we're
going to subtract it from
the gross profit.
So what does the gross
profit have to be?
In order for this to come out
to be zero, the gross profit
has to be $500,000.
And so now we can think of a
bunch of scenarios where we
end up with $500,000
gross profit.
We could, if we sold--
what'd we say?
So how can we get to $500,000?
So let's say we're selling, I
don't know, instead of selling
a million cupcakes we're only
selling 500,000 cupcakes.
Right this should work out.
So then our revenue
will be $500,000.
And let's say I'm still selling
it for $2 a cupcake.
Times $2.
So that would be $1 million
of revenue coming into
the door per year.
And then my cost of cupcakes,
or my cost of
goods sold, is what?
I should be doing this in red,
I'm not being consistent.
My cost of goods sold is what?
We said it was a dollar
per cupcake, right?
So that's 500,000 times $1.
It would be silly to ever sell
a cupcake for less than a
dollar, right?
Then you're just handing
checks out to
your cupcake eaters.
But anyway, in this case, my
cost for goods sold would be
$500,000 and everything
would work out.
So this is a break-even
scenario, where I sell 500,000
cupcakes at $2 per cupcake,
with this
being the cost of goods.
And then I'll make $500,000
gross profit and then, take
out the overhead.
At least I won't make a loss.
This is interesting because this
tells me, if I'm charging
$2 per cupcake, I have to sell
at least 500,000 cupcakes to
make money.
So you might say, oh yeah, so it
would never be rational to
sell anything less than
500,000 cupcakes.
Otherwise you should not
operate the business.
And what we'll do in future
videos is we'll actually
explore situations in which
that does happen.
And in which people start
to kind of cut
prices to actually compete.
And in the process they'll be
doing very irrational things.
But anyway, I realize I've run
out of time in this video.
I'll see you in the next one
and we'll actually see what
happens once I start
my cupcake factory.